bienvenue dans là où ça bouge avec jet
dé nous cette exposition jeux de nous a
lieu dans trois endroits le premier ici
au musée des beaux-arts de caen ensuite
le musée radar de bayeux et puis il
reste encore un endroit c'est l'hôpital
psychiatrique de bayeux parce que ce
sont des patients qui ont réalisé aussi
ses oeuvres avec votre soutien
évidemment oui alors ça a été une très
grande rencontre avec 80 patients des
enfants des plus grandes et plus âgés
c'est vraiment l'histoire du petit
poucet c'est comme ça que je travaille
en tant qu'artiste r je me balade
je prospecte j'explore les territoires
donc ça commence par un pas un rapport
très aventure très ludique et on s'amuse
et on joue ensemble c'est à dire oui
c'est cool il y a trois mois pour
présenter la victoire l'allemagne voit
mal parce que ça doit obtenir un
logement après nombreux débats et donné
aux démarches
on croit tous que nos sensations sont
acquises et en fait il ya un truc c'est
qu'on vit de manière dépossédés voilà
c'est qu'à force d'avancer
et bien nos sens parfois on a tendance à
aller oubliez donc c'est un travail qui
se repose essentiellement sur des petits
riens du quotidien qui fait que nos
éveil sont constamment suscité il
discutait longtemps et traverser paris
il était marqué par leur passé ils
étaient loin d'être bête il est défini
fils ils créent chaque jour de l'an
promenade en forêt pourquoi trois lieux
d'exposition pour ce jeu de nous trois
lieux parce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans
une économie solidaire
voilà donc il faut rassembler les forces
c'est bien votre joie de vivre ça fait
du bien
après cette belle exposition on va
repartir en musique avec jazz escale 10e
édition bel anniversaire sac merci
comment ce soir avec ce concert de
verona groupes de la région groupes de
la région avec une artiste invité micha
fitzgerald michel certainement l'un des
meilleurs guitaristes de la scène jazz
européenne actuelle
vous
dix ans ici sales legoupil à ouistreham
pour fêter le jazz et notamment aussi
vendredi vendredi avec la venue
exceptionnelle d'un magnifique ensemble
électro pop acoustique de magnetic
ensemble six musiciens la salle va
décoller
dubois
et toi tu as
qu'est ce qui se passe est l'histoire
alors un bal avec le big band de touche
dehors dans la salle le goupil pour
marquer les 10 ans du festival mais sera
dedans oui bien sûr dehors dedans les
dix ans de jazz escale on va tout de
suite repartir dans les expositions avec
mathieu belinga ni bertrand goulet qui
sont à cherbourg matures vous avez l'air
de douter la ccvy c'est bien une
exposition on verra bien jacques on
verra bien c'est d'ailleurs le titre de
l'exposition à la mjc de cherbourg et
puis je vais essayer moi aussi d'exposer
mon petit dessin puisque c'est l'auberge
espagnole de l'exposition
pas mal non stéphanie je peux venir ici
exposé mes dessins c'est ce que ça
fonctionne oui c'est ça l'idée que cette
exposition on verra lien s'est imposé
aucune contrainte aucune consigne c'est
jusqu'au 12 mars
on a proposé non pas traditionnellement
c'est un vernissage pour un début
d'exposition et là en plus propose
plutôt de faire un dévernissage un pot
de clôture qui permettra à chacun de
venir parler son objet de rencontrer
d'autres personnes pour le coup je pense
que beaucoup de gens ne se connaissent
pas et c'est aussi un moyen de rencontre
merci mathieu on termine avec les wampas
qui seront vendredi au carnaval de
granville avec un message
bonne soirée